[Music]
thank you
I've been trying to visit other World
Cups I did not have the opportunity
alhamdulillah my country brought that
opportunity to me in my country guitar
is more than ready and I feel so excited
and proud very proud I came to the Asian
game in 2006 and I brought my little
daughter when she was six years old
and today she brought me hair as a
promise 12 years ago
and she said I will take you to the
World Cup and this is really an
outstanding
I was actually very happy we didn't get
tickets until today today morning so it
was like last minute yeah and uh I just
feel like it was only meant to be oh it
was easy and I was delighted to get the
ticket
yeah that's not a question well of
course
we'll see Qatar inshallah obviously
guitar like you know till the end yeah I
I think Germany will win
we've spent a lot of money time
planning on all of this to see it come
true it's an actual honor for us
honestly an honor everyone comes to our
country to see our culture our
traditions for me as for me as a Qatari
and for me as an Arabic and for a Muslim
nations it's first time to come to the
one of the Arab countries and to the
Middle East
and we are proud of it
when people jealous people see you
succeed
they'll talk and they'll speak and they
say no this is wrong this is wrong you
just continue on hey they don't they
don't know the whole story just a big
drama don't Focus
well I think whoever criticize us better
to come and see this event this is the
answer
[Applause]